au travail et ainsi de suite et ainsi de
suite donc ça c'est c'est vraiment il ya
ce besoin de travailler sur les valeurs
et d'acceptation de la société et ça
aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on aime évoquer
tout à l'heure ce maillon faible qui
persistent et qui finalement sera aussi
présent en afrique mais pour l'instant
comme en afrique on a cette capacité
d'avoir encore quelques coups et queen
et d'accès aux soins
mais finalement sur les chiffres ça se
ça se répercute différemment merci merci
beaucoup merci encore madame senequier
je rappelle vous êtes chercheuse
associée à layrisse merci d'avoir
apporté votre éclairage dans cette
émission
cette partie là n'est pas encore
terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et non
[Musique]
bienvenue dans pôle it mag spécial
élections municipales les français ont
la parole pendant toute la campagne on
va tenter de comprendre quelles sont vos
préoccupations au quotidien avec des
reportages sur le terrain vos remarques
et vos questions sur nos réseaux sociaux
et bien sûr le débat avec nos invités
sur ce plateau la qualité alimentaire
passe-t-elle par les circuits courts
un modèle qui séduit de plus en plus les
français
pas ou peu d'intermédiaires traçabilité
des produits faible kilométrage et
renforcement des liens entre le
consommateur et le producteur
aujourd'hui près d'un français sur deux
a recours aux circuits courts agricoles
est ce une alternative à la
mondialisation pourront parler nous
sommes avec denise vuillon maraîchère
dans le var et cofondatrice du réseau
amap association pour le maintien de
l'agriculture paysanne et face à vous à
l'inde aux langues l'agriculteur
agriculteur bio à argentan dans l'orne
quentin le guillou représentants des
jeunes agriculteurs merci à tous d'être
là sur ce plateau d'ayrté france
première question pour vous de mi
juillet vous défendez évidemment ce
modèle de circuit court est ce que vous
pouvez nous dire comment ça fonctionne
exactement une amap c'est un partenariat
avec des consommateurs qui s'engagent
financièrement à l'avance c'est avant
tout une alternative économique c'est
bien grâce à ça fait une c'est très
positif c'est bien grâce à ça que notre
ferme est toujours là parce qu'en fait
le prix du panier assure la viabilité de
la ferme il est calculé c'est un prix
comptable il est calculé pour que la
ferme puisse continuer son activité on a
créé des emplois et surtout on a permis
donc aux consommateurs qu'ils avaient
envie de savoir ce qui m'était dans leur
assiette puisque la map est né
moment de la crise de la vache folle en
2001 mais c'est pas la chute de 2009
était la sécurité alimentaire qui les a
fait venir à nous venir vers nous et
nous se trouve qu'on était en pleine
crise agricole on disparaissait les
fermes maraîchères autour des villes ce
sont des premières fermes ont
agriculture la ferme maraîchère elle a
toujours été au tour des villes c'était
la première fois qu'il taille de petite
taille à taille humaine des fermes
maraîchères sont des fermes familiales
en général et bons ballons disparu et
nous on est une ferme en zone
périurbaine et donc grâce à ses
consommateurs qui étaient en recherche
de produits de qualité sanitaire mais
aussi gustatives c'est important
voilà on a répondu on a été mis en
contact
en 2001 on a répondu présent et on a
expliqué qu'on allait disparaître
donc ça a donné une un sens
supplémentaire au fait de vous mangez
bien mais en plus vous permettez à la
ferme dehaudt et à la terre aride
agricole de résister mais c'est un sujet
qui préoccupe particulièrement les
français le bien manger alain de l'angle
ces circuits courts ça fonctionne
comment exactement il ne faut pas
d'intermédiaires c'est de la vente
directe du producteur au consommateur
est-ce qu'il ya d'autres circuits
juste une petite rectification j'habite
à saint fraimbault c'est par j'entends
c'est une cinquantaine kilomètres mais
voilà c'est important pour nous dans le
monde rural
il ya ce alors les circuits courts
s'inscrivent dans une diversité en fait
de commercialisation faut pas imaginer
que tous france ricour et
par contre il ya un rééquilibrage qui
est en train de se faire on a beaucoup
imaginent et les circuits plus complexe
qu'on appelait les circuits au travers
de la gms et tout ça et aujourd'hui
c'est que la gms exagéré c'est la grande
et moyenne surface même pas parler les
hypermarchés et les supermarchés et
aujourd'hui donc par rapport à la
demande du consommateur mais aussi par
rapport à un sou et des producteurs il y
a
chez chez tout le monde lui envie de
diversifier les circuits de
commercialisation ce qui finalement est
plutôt intéressant parce qu'on sait très
bien que les bénévoles et la grande
distribution étaient arrivés avant
d'entamer ne pas lui ce qu'il ya
aujourd'hui quatre cinq acheteurs pour
les produits agricoles
donc ça va créer de la diversification
versification on va retrouver des
magasins de producteurs par exemple on
va retrouver des réseaux de magasins
spécialisés puisque nous on est en
agriculture biologique est spécialisée
en bio par exemple
donc tout ça ça crée une diversité et
quand on dit qu'aujourd'hui il faut
sauvegarder la biodiversité c'est bien
qu'ils aient aussi une biodiversité dans
la distribution alors il ya peu
d'intermédiaires ans c'est le principe
du circuit court il peut y en avoir un
via les restaurateurs les grands chefs
aussi qu'ils font beaucoup la promotion
de ces circuits courts peu
d'intermédiaires quentin le bio en quoi
est ce un gage de qualité
un gage de qualité un gage de revenus
aussi pour l'agriculteur un gage de
qualité parce que les consommateurs vont
acheter directement à l'agriculteur ils
savent ils peuvent même poser les
questions à l'agriculteur pour savoir ce
qu'ils vont manger dans leur assiette ce
que l'agriculteur a pu appliquer sur la
culture ou sur ses légumes ses fruits
etc
qu'ils soient en bio ou pas pour ça il
faut que ce soit de bonne foi aussi pour
ça faut qu'ils soient de bonne foi
maintenant quand on commence à vendre à
la ferme et à ouvrir un petit peu ses
portes
il est difficile de tout cacher voilà il
ya un moment il faut être de bonne foi
il faut attraper la confiance du
consommateur
il ya comme ça qu'on y arrive donc c'est
vraiment un gage de traçabilité
également le consommateur sait
exactement d'où vient le produit c'est
parti c'est une préoccupation c'est ce
que vous entendez souvent de la part du
consommateur il faut savoir maintenant
d'où vient le produit de plus en plus
mauvais les consommateurs maintenant
attendre un produit de qualité
une proximité ils veulent plus des
aliments qui font le tour du monde pour
arriver dans nos assiettes
donc en ramenant du des produits qui
viennent des fois d'une commune
de leur commune ou de la commune d'à
côté on arrive à rattacher ce lien avec
le consommateur de qualité dans des
circuits courts on l'a dit qu'il fédère
de plus en plus dans les territoires
illustration notamment dans une petite
commune du berry à selles sur cher
exactement une commune de 4600 aux
habitants aux confins du berry de la
sologne notamment nos reporters sont
allés sur place n'a déjà des razak et
lucas tu as regardé et guillaume séchet
32 ans producteur de 9 de pâturage vous
revenez la semaine prochaine ça marche
merci on voit bien que l'agriculture
française à peine à valoriser ses
produits il ya des systèmes qui sont en
route depuis longtemps qui font de la
quantité
malheureusement bas
c'est très fragile quoi alors qu'en
étant plus petit on maîtrise beaucoup
mieux sa vie parce que si je m'étais
installé
dans ce domaine là par exemple affaires
l'industriel à faire du chiffre
jme serait débarrassé un petit peu de
deux de ma production au détriment de la
qualité
voilà là je fais un peu plus de qualité
plus petite échelle
et puis d'essayer d'être d'être autonome
et puis depuis de pouvoir
avoir une vision sur l'avenir et voilà
merci vous aussi bonjour au revoir
mangez frais bio et local et les clients
sont de plus en plus friands quitte à
mettre la main au porte-monnaie pour
trouver les bons produits bien plus tôt
que dans les supermarchés quoi voilà et
puis c'est le sondé comment comme on dit
des produits locaux et pour les
producteurs locaux faire travailler les
gens quand même voilà quitte à payer un
peu plus cher
je m'en fiche je veux de la qualité
et puis les produits frais c'est quand
même meilleur que les conserves et tout
le reste c'est pour ça que j'achète
beaucoup marché pour les connaissez des
commerçants qu'on connaît depuis
longtemps on sait que ces frais que ces
garanties à une garantie qu'on mange
mieux
donc on retrouve un bienfait et l'argent
qu'on met dans la nourriture mais
pendant le médicament
guillaume séchet ce n'est pas le seul
agriculteur de la région favoriser les
circuits courts à montmorillon elle
c'est tout un marché bio et local qui a
ouvert ses portes en 2014
quatre demi journées par semaine il
propose les produits et d'une
quarantaine d'agriculteurs locaux
le fait de vendre en direct ça a réduit
les commissions qui sont prises par les
grossistes et semi-grossistes enfin et
du coup les
les producteurs vendent au prix de leur
travail et le consommateur lui en
échange il a appris qui est équitable
pour lui aussi parce qu'effectivement le
producteur va pas
rajouter sur son prix de vente les
marges que pour elle dû prendre une
grande distribution
par ailleurs on est soucieux du
kilométrage du carburant et cetera
voilà et derrière soucieux d'abord de la
production de la qualité de la
production
là on a deux gammes on a du bio et du
non bio mais le non bio il sera tracée à
istres à 100 100 produits mais sans
appellation bio
on consomme peut-être un peu moins et de
meilleure qualité
voilà là je pense que la majoritairement
maintenant les gens ils en ont marre des
produits chimiques d eux quelque chose
des listes comme ça sur chaque produit
donc ça il ya vraiment une éducation qui
est en train de se faire avec génération
les médias je pense que les gens sont
sensibles à ça moi c'est important de se
voir j'aime bien savoir ce que je mange
donc je les produits soient sains c'est
pour moi c'est indispensable pour mon
équilibre
vous l'aurez compris les circuits courts
agricoles connaissent envie succès ici
dans la région
il assure en effet la préservation de
l'environnement la juste rémunération
des producteurs et la qualité nutritive
des aliments du gagnant gagnant en somme
autant pour le producteur que le
consommateur on va là pour ce reportage
signé un adage abderrazak et les cas tu
as on entendu cet agriculteur dans ce
reportage d'hier quand on est un petit
on maîtrise mieux sa vie alain de
langues
vous vous comprenez oui c'est vrai que
ça peut soit plus producteurs comme le
consommateur la notion de transparence
la notion d' échanges de liens
elle est fondamentale avec ne pas
résoudre comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure
tous forcément tous les volumes et
toutes les situations mais on voit bien
qu'il ya cet aspect de petite taille
incompatible avec ses circuits courts
mais cela dit la notion de recherche de
la transparence de de connaître la
vérité c'est important et on a vécu sans
doute trop d'années où les produits ont
été marqués t et marc était des fois
sans vouloir montrer les choses telles
qu'elles étaient plutôt on a le souvenir
de deux choses d'un pot de lait qui
montrait un yaourt et on sait très bien
que c'est plus fait comme ça quoi donc
ça peut faire rêver les gens mais il
faut faire attention de ne pas s'écarter
trop de la réalité et montrer les choses
telles qu'elles sont et vous disiez les
intermédiaires reste néanmoins
indispensable dans l'agriculture
évidemment pour distribuer vos produits
ben je crois que si vous allez ringier
c'est vous dites que le marché de rungis
ne sert à rien je pense que
il ya des gens qui vont sauver et les
parisiens risquent de manquer de
nourriture très vite que donc on voit
bien qu'il ya aussi ce besoin de
complémentarité d'acteurs alors ces
circuits courts ça représente à peu près
6 à 7% des achats alimentaires denise
vuillon est ce qu'il ya un regain
d'intérêt ce que vous sentez vraiment
que les français vont davantage vers ces
circuits courts voilà moi j'ai bien
entendu dans le reportage qui était
intéressant c'est que pratiquement à
100% les gens vont ont besoin d'abord de
se contacter de liens il ya un an soit
un lien de retour à la terre ça c est au
plan aussi qualitatif quand on voit
quelqu'un ya la question de confiance
comme tu disais tout à l'heure on sent
que c'est très important
c'est vraiment important et il voit là
bas nous ça s'est quand même vingt ans
qu'on a commencé c'est ce concept mais
il ya toujours plus de demandes et l'âge
moyen des amapiens comme on dit
aujourd'hui c'est la trentaine avait ce
qu'on voyait dans ce reportage aussi
beaucoup de personnages et forcément de
la glace et l'habitude déjà les jeunes
parents les jeunes russes faire le
marché
les gens ne vont pas tirer mais par
contre à l'époque en 2001 quand la map
est née cette aide et des retraités des
gens mobilisés un peu hâte
altermondialiste d'aujourd'hui cdfa nice
et des jeunes gens vraiment parce que la
nourriture qu'ils donnent à leurs
enfants c'est important est important de
savoir d'où ça vient
et bon c'est sûr qu'en maraîchage on n'a
pas besoin d'intermédiaire
mais voilà tout le monde tous les
produits ne peuvent pas se distribuer
comme un produits maraîchers qui est
cueilli le matin et distribué laabidi
alors quelqu'un de produits précisément
peuvent rester en circuit court alors on
a vu ces sont les producteurs de miel
qui ont commencé d'abord à vendre leur
miel directement aux consommateurs
ça a fait boule de neige les fruits et
légumes
le lait la viande c'est plus compliqué
la viande c'est plus compliqué mais on
en trouve on a dès aujourd'hui des
éleveurs uni en ile-de-france aussi
malgré la baisse des éleveurs parce que
bon voilà on demande aujourd'hui de la
qualité et un rapprochement vers un
contact vers l'agriculture pour mieux
manger du local et autres mais pour moi
par exemple qui du coup d'île de france
on voit une chute aujourd'hui des
éleveurs donc on les quelques éleveurs
qui reste arrive à vendre à la ferme
avec des caissettes vous faut commander
trois semaines avant les gens viennent
bon on entend des fois les prix sont un
peu supérieurs mais la qualité est là
voilà est-ce que c'est vraiment plus
cher ou pas on parle de 20 à 30% de prix
supplémentaires par rapport à ce qu'on
peut acheter 20 comprend dix 10 ans et
peut-être je pense que c'est exagéré
peut-être un peu voilà exagéré après il
ya des produits de qualité il faut quand
même pouvoir les payer
30% je pense que c'est peut-être un
petit peu exagéré voilà et puis bon bah
après aussi il en faut pour tout l'est
pour tous les revenus 100% circuits
courts ça peut être compliqué comme le
disait pour pour certains aliments voilà
il ya des aliments où il faut passer des
fois par des petites gms où on arrive
encore certains endroits avoir des bons
contacts
après quand on arrive avec des grandes
gm est cela qui est qui qui qui nous
assomme c'est sûr que c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué mais aujourd'hui le miel
on arrive à le vendre à la ferme
avec ma femme nous on s'est lancé du
coup dans des productions de pâtes pâte
à la ferme non moi je suis en grandes
cultures que des céréales et grâce aux
circuits courts donc gratifier voilà bah
en fait n'être plus tôt à cause d'un
manque de revenus et en fait c'est là
aujourd'hui peut-être le problème pour
certaines exploitations où il va à cause
d'un manque de revenus il a fallu nous
diversifier trouver nouvelle valeur
ajoutée à une nouvelle source de revenus
pour l'exploitation pour rester viable
dans ce monde aujourd'hui donc on a
lancé aujourd'hui d'aider des pâtes avec
le blé dur qui est fait sur la ferme on
transforme tout le produit on peut le
vendre à la ferme mais pas que on va le
vendre aussi avec des épiceries fines ou
à proximité des commerces de proximité
voilà qui aujourd'hui sont capables de
nous les prendre qu'ils se prennent leur
petite marche bien entendues pour fermer
la montée des commerces aussi de vendre
du noble et oui il ya une volonté de
retourner du losc en finale
voilà on arrive à faire une entente
les gens veulent du local eh ben on le
ramène les produits les gens veulent du
local alain de l'angle comment est-ce
que l'agriculteur finalement qui vend en
circuits courts s'y retrouvent en termes
de 2,2 de prix pour lui de revenus en
tout cas on sait que les agriculteurs
ont du mal à joindre les deux bouts à la
fin du mois alors ça dépendra quel
modèle moi je suis agriculteur
biologique depuis plus de 20 ans et en
longtemps été en filière longue a pas
très longtemps qu'on a développé une
filière de commercialisation en vente
directe vous êtes des précurseurs
finalement et claudio un de ces circuits
il ya 23 ans oui on l'a fait parce qu'en
fait il ya une notion de rats course
pour raccourcir les circuits cas même
dans la bio c'est que si vous prenez
deux verres de lait côte-à-côte si vous
avez un verre de lait qui est produit
avec du maïs et du soja qui vient du
brésil
le producteur il peut être à quelques
kilomètres mais la production elle a
fait l à déforester ans en amérique du
sud
le principe de la bio c'est de produire
de façon autonome c'est-à-dire que la
première relocalisation s'est créé sur
sa ferme un système qui permet de façon
autonome à sortir le maximum de
production nous la production principale
pour faire le laisser l'herbe et des
céréales qui sont produites sur la ferme
on n'a pas un kilo de ce genre acheter
en dehors de chez nous donc ça veut dire
que c'est la première proximité qui
était qui est importante derrière le nom
l'a pas fait parce que on gagnait pas
notre vie en filiales ont on l'a fait à
la fois pour pour le plaisir de
diversifier comme je disais tout à
l'heure les circuits aussi innové avec
une production de foin culinaire en chef
d'ailleurs comment point que vous donnez
aux grands chefs on vend un grand chef
et qu'on travaille on travaille des
produits type là je dis qu'on a là aussi
avec un chef un euro au près de chez
nous donc il ya ce côté recherche
innovation qui est en fait aussi quelque
chose de valorisant pour un agriculteur
et recherche innovation toujours en
ayant à l'esprit cette qualité c'est
vraiment le mot n'a alors il ya la
qualité
il ya aussi donc la notion de proximité
aujourd'hui elle peut se faire il ya des
outils parce qu'il ya la logistique est
toujours l'élément logistique est un
un élément crucial est aujourd'hui des
logistiques qui permettent nous le x par
exemple en commercialise par colissimo
on peut aussi on fait aussi de la viande
surgelée la viande surgelée aujourd'hui
on peut elle peut s'envoyer
effectivement par crown of chrono frise
appelle et on peut donc oui aujourd'hui
il ya la logistique pour le faire et le
e-commerce est pas forcément un
une seule une seule plateforme grandes
plateformes dont je dirai pas le nom
mais qui est bien connu mais il ya déjà
vous dire comme on peut retrouver des
petits commerces on peut retrouver des
petits sites de vente où on va être
direct en direct avec le producteur et
finalement la marge pour faire le coup
pour transporter va pas être plus
forcément plus élevé que la marche qu'on
va laisser normalement un magasin pour
qu'ils vivent pas et est donc denise
vuillon le l'agricultrice que vous êtes
s'y retrouvent en termes de marges
justement au vent dans ses circuits
courts vous aussi rodin de beaucoup de
domaines je dirais économiquement
évidemment je voulais expliquer que le
prix du panier c'est un prix comptable
donc on sait combien il nous faut par
rapport au sérieux c'est une péréquation
et par rapport à la surface quand on
sait combien de damas piane de famille
on peut avoir et notre potentiel de de
terre quoi de surface et on divise donc
notre nombre de consommateurs par ce qui
a été le ladino j'agis en circuit court
est plus intéressante que si vous
vendiez auront 10 train de vous enlever
de la marche des intermédiaires c'est
énorme
nous c'est vraiment la seule façon pour
nous impose hier maraîchère à nice et
c'est énorme
là est bon alors il ya ce facteur là qui
nous a permis d'être toujours là ça
n'avait pas eu la maca longtemps qu'on
aurait disparu il ya aussi la recherche
de la qualité pour nos savez le déclic
chez nous ça a été la tomate par exemple
quand la tomate elle a été sur les étals
toute l'année et dans les gms sympa
surtout là on ne retrouve plus le goût
de la tomate sas afin d qliq parce que
c'est un fruit quand même voilà les gens
viennent à daniela était vraiment à
l'origine du du redéploiement des
tomates anciennes savaient qu'ils ont du
goût évidemment c'est pas parce qu'elles
sont anciennes c'est parce que c'est des
bonnes variétés qui ont du goût et vous
serez avons mis au goût du jour des
légumes qu'ils étaient oubliées
finalement oui au cou mais de saison il
faut respecter les saisons si vous ne
pouvez pas avoir même s'il est oublié si
vous le fais pousser n'importe quand
forcé s'ouvre est l'un des serres
chauffées on attend on attend aussi le
volet environ
si voilà donc un volet économique volée
que satisfait aussi valeur de statut
c'est énorme on a les grands chefs qui
sont partenaires aussi ils prennent
comme départ de paniers comme des
amapiens pour avoir nos produits de
qualité on a beaucoup beaucoup de grands
chefs et s'éteint c'est un circuit
finalement quentin le bio qui a permis
aussi de recruter qui demande plus de
main-d'oeuvre finalement donc il ya
c'est que ces créateurs d'emplois les
circuits courts
ça permet de créer l'emploi bat déjà sur
les exploitations qui se lancent en
circuit court bien souvent dans les
années qui suivent ont tendance à
augmenter leurs projets et à embaucher
et en plus derrière ben voilà sur le
transport
et bah ça crée de l'emploi sur les amap
des emplois ont été créés voilà de
l'emploi et crée toutes parts et on le
voit en île de france par exemple l'une
des fermes mixte qui font ces lieux du
circuit court ont une moyenne de 76
hectares de surfaces agricoles et 4,4
employés pardon contrairement à
quelqu'un qui aurait 136 hectares et 1,2
employé en moyenne pour un circuit
conventionnel donc on le voit c'est du
simple au double finalement plus petite
moitié n'est deux fois plus de
d'employés c'est vraiment le circuit ou
du moins la diversification qui a permis
l'embauché
aujourd'hui sur une exploitation aux
moyennes grandes cultures bien souvent
l'agriculteur l'exploitant est peut-être
un salarié à mi-temps ou avec un avec un
voisin lui nope voilà il n'a pas
forcément besoin de prendre de salariés
supplémentaires
faire pousser du blé voilà dès qu'on se
lance dans toutes ses productions là qui
est plus technique qui demande beaucoup
plus de temps un maraîcher aujourd'hui
il y est tous les jours dans ses champs
à des mauvaises herbes les récoltes
l'hérault semis et c'est donc cesser
plus vraiment la même méthode agricole
que pourrait être quelqu'un en
conventionnel ou en bio en grandes
cultures
voilà ces nouvelles activités donc
création d'emplois un quiz de respect
pour l'environnement
avec plus de respect pour
l'environnement bien sûr si on respecte
les saisons comme on l'a dit voilà
aujourd'hui quand on voit des fraises à
noël ou des tomates aussi à noël
voilà ça ça pose problème c'est l'accès
à pose question aujourd'hui il faut
revenir
c'est ce qu'on dit aux gens pour venir
sur des produits de saison et locales
pour faire vivre les agriculteurs locaux
avec des produits vraiment sain de
saison de qualité
alain de l'anglais mentalités ont changé
des personnes qui voulaient des fraises
en hiver ou autres voulaient les
français reviennent justement de leurs
demandes extravagantes parfois c'est
assez rigolo de voir à quel point le
citoyen est en train de faire changer le
monde agricole aujourd'hui par
l'engouement de la bio par exemple c'est
bien une demande
je dirais que c'est quand même plus un
engouement des consommateurs qu'une
volonté politique qui pour l'instant a
du mal à y croire
voilà c'est vraiment la notion de la
consommation on a un phénomène a inversé
c'est celui du dépeuplement des
campagnes et là encore je suis persuadé
qu' il y à dents dans les villes
aujourd'hui des jeunes qui ont envie de
faire un retour en campagne qui vont
reprendre des cafés dans des débats il
ya un programme qui prévoit
l'installation de deux mille cafés dans
l'est dans des petites communes rurales
dont il ya quelque chose qui est en
train de s'inverser mais j'ai envie de
rider positif plutôt c'est petit tous
les secteurs mais c'est quand même
quelque part urgent parce que on est
rendu à un point où ça devient
pratiquement inacceptable c'est
dangereux pour l'environnement
et pour la survie des agriculteurs ou la
survie des agriculteurs pour parce qu'on
voit bien il ya un film qui a fait un
grand grand succès au nom de la terre et
qui montre quand même une situation qui
est malheureusement réel et si beaucoup
avec des suicides et donc je pense qu'on
est arrivé le temps où faut relier le
monde rural et le monde urbain et
moi j'essaie de mener aussi un combat gg
j'ai été militant au sein du réseau
fiable pour le développement de la bio
pendant plus de 20 ans aujourd'hui je
j'ai créé une association qui s'appelle
campa city avec l'objectif de recréer du
lien entre le monde rural et le monde
urbain et on va en parler justement dans
la deuxième partie on rester avec nous
on continue ce débat sur les circuits
courts agricoles en france
quels sont les avantages et les limites
de ce modèle de plus en plus plébiscités
par les français
on en parle dans quelques minutes restez
avec nous
[Musique]
il faut bien comprendre que les champs
de schiste pétroliers américains donc
quelques temps vont s'arrêter de
produire si vous voulez toutes les
données pétrolières sont confidentielles
est ce qu'on peut imaginer qu'à terme
avec le pétrole de schiste les
américains soient énergétiquement
indépendant ben non ils sont en train de
frôler l'indépendance mais pour le pour
le gars cylisme en mai pour le pétrole
non c'est puis là le pigiste sont des
puits qui donne le maximum
les premiers mois après c'est une chute
continuelle
si les pétroles de schiste des cent
cette année
suffisamment pour que ça square notable
en moins devant brême ne sera pareil
[Musique]
oui
ou est-ce qu'on en est au niveau de la
radicalisation dans le sport que le
terme radicalisation c'est un peu un mot
valise et ont même beaucoup de choses
qui ne reflète pas la réalité non pas de
la radicalisation islamiste dans le
sport c'est tout ce processus qui peut
conduire quelqu'un à se mettre en marge
totale de la société parfois même
basculer vers l'action violente en 2016
- sportif considéré que c'était pas son
affaire et qu'il n'avait pas à être une
sorte de délateurs des pouvoirs parce
que le sujet c'est qu'aujourd'hui toute
une série de phénomènes nous échappe
ce sont ces associations qui se crée ou
bien des structures qui se créent en
dehors du mouvement organisé certains
ont dit le sport amateur c'est le
premier lieu vecteur de radicalisation
c'est faux c'est la prison dans les
clubs
il peut y avoir des cas de prosélytisme
mais pas contre les radicaliser ne vont
plus à la mosquée ne sont plus à l'école
ne sont plus dans les clubs
retirez vos de la tête le sport
associatif
[Musique]
pôle it mag la suite le bien manger et
le respect de l'environnement passe-t-il
par les circuits courts
ce système offre t-il une alternative à
la mondialisation on en parle avec nos
invités sur ce plateau denise vuillon
maraîchère dans le var et cofondatrice
du réseau amap association pour le
maintien de l'agriculture paysanne
on en parle également avec alain de
l'angle agriculteurs bio dans l'orne et
et quentin le guillou représentant des
jeunes les agriculteurs les circuits
courts entre producteurs et
consommateurs se multiplient en france
plus de 40 % des français ont déjà eu
recours aux circuits courts
un modèle économique viable pour les
agriculteurs c'est la question qu'on se
pose éléments de réponse tout d'abord
avec david khalifa regarder la vente
directe de l'agriculture au consommateur
est une pratique qui prend un essor
considérable ces dernières années en
cause une prise de conscience croissante
pour une alimentation plus durable car
quand un produit est acheminée
directement du producteur au client cela
permet d'économiser du temps de
l'emballage et des émissions dues au
transport et cette fameuse prise de
conscience et une source de revenus non
négligeable pour le secteur de
l'agriculture au bord du précipice en
france et en europe
les chiffres parlent d'eux mêmes en
moyenne les agriculteurs l'union
européenne ne reçoivent que 21 % de
l'argent payé par les consommateurs pour
leurs produits le reste est grignotée
par les intermédiaires soit en moyenne
28% pour les transformateurs et 51% pour
la grande distribution
une situation qui rend les producteurs
fortement dépendant des grandes chaînes
alimentaires vous l'aurez compris leurs
positions négociations est extrêmement
faible dans cette industrie
malheureusement passé aux circuits
courts n'est pas évident pour tout le
monde en 2015 la part des aliments
commercialisés en circuits courts ne
représentaient que 5 % de la valeur
totale des produits agricoles en europe
principaux obstacles manque d'argent de
personnel de capacités logistiques et de
publicité pour mettre en place un tel
concept qui plus est
difficile de mettre en place un système
de livraison individuelles surtout pour
les plus petites exploitations
mais en france les chiffres sont plutôt
encourageants et de plus en plus
d'agriculteurs tente le coup la tendance
à augmenter de 19 à 21% dans les 30
dernières années
alain delon parler des du lien entre les
villes et ces fameux circuits courts
agricoles
finalement ce sont les villes les
meilleures ambassadrices de ces circuits
courts c'est là où il ya le plus de
monde aujourd'hui c'est là où ça
bouillonne c'est là où il ya pas mal
d'innovations
maintenant il faut que ça titan nation
cette innovation pardon elles
redescendent et elle se fasse dans une
forme de coopération entre le monde
rural et le monde urbain et ça c'est ce
que vous avez essayé de faire c'est de
reconnecter finalement les villes au
monde agricole on ça marche on travaille
dessus moi je travaille dessus depuis
trois quatre ans on a officialisé un
premier jumelage ou une première
coopération puisque l'on est sur le le
concept du jumelage entre la commune à
saint fraimbault et le xviiie
arrondissement de paris
et l'idée c'est de de se connaître mieux
et de faire des choses ensemble sur
l'éducation sur la coopération
économique font tout simplement le
passage d'événement c'est se connaître
et à partir de là les choses vont vont
faire que on va pouvoir compte peut-être
construire des des circuits peut-être
trouvé une coopération sur le logement
par exemple quand on sait que le
problème en ville c'est de se loger
le problème en campagne c'est de mettre
des gens dans les maisons donc à un
moment si les gens se rencontrent on
dira mais finalement si si j'allais
vivre à la campagne et comment ça se
passe concrètement les logements il faut
que ce soit quand même assez proche de
paris j'imagine oui mais il peut y avoir
des personnes qui comme ça se faisait
par le lien familial et une époque il y
avait beaucoup de personnes qui allaient
travailler à la ville du captif d'été à
l'âge de la retraite et venait tout
simplement revenir à la campagne où ils
avaient eu leur enfance mais comme il
n'y a plus ou très peu de lien familial
aujourd'hui c'est le rôle des élus dans
les chapelles les élus les futures
équipes là qui vont être en place après
les élections à venir à venir retrouver
campa city pour justement comprendre la
méthode haut pour pouvoir créer ce lien
ville campagne alors ce lien ville
campagne
vous en aviez parlé aussi denise vuillon
c'est sans les villes finalement vous
vous n'existe riez pas voilà est en fait
notre ferme et et c'est la proximité
donne avec la ville qui nous a permis de
les rencontrer ces consommateurs qui
nous ont soutenus et traditionnellement
finalement ce circuit court c'étaient
les villes qui allait acheter
voilà d'abord périphérie voilà les
villes avaient des ceintures vertes
avant n'existait déjà relâché c'est le
premier qui ont disparu à cause de
l'agrandissement et l'illusion qu'ils
ont installé d'ailleurs les gms autour
des villes ils ont contribué beaucoup à
la disparition des étés ferme
c'est pour ça que la disparition de ces
petites fermes donc tout pratiquement
toute la petite agriculture a été
dévalorisée elle s'est perdue et c'est
pour ça que la map qui a été facile à
faciliter un par les petites fermes
familiales
ben on a vu des producteurs qui se sont
qui ont été revalorisés par ces gens qui
venaient de la ville revendables la
revalorisation de leur métier internet y
est pour beaucoup également honte et
parce qu'il faut aussi faire de la
promotion ou j'imagine main pour pouvoir
aujourd'hui on utilise beaucoup quand on
a commencé on était très peu on
utilisait très peu il ya vingt ans qu'on
a commencé la première map
aujourd'hui c'est un bon outil ça nous
permet de défier d'avoir notre liste de
diffusion et de citer une grande
communication et a besoin de communiquer
dans la mare vous savez que les en
partage les aléas aussi donc sans arrêt
besoin d'informer les gens on a les
oiseaux tx des aléas c'est à dire c'est
à dire voilà on a par exemple cet été
des vols de
de tout cas de choucas des tours on
connaissait pas cet oiseau qui est venu
en bande qui nous a mangé toute la pole
tout le semi de chou qui organise les
gens là en partie ce partage ça veut
dire qu'ils n'ont pas eu de shu où on a
replanté on commence à peine à voir des
choses je sais pas si vous connaissez
les produits sont de chou mais c'est
très tard d'ivoire les gens partagent
les aléas
donc nous ne partage sa production si
quelqu'un c'est complètement une
production partagée achète en fait ici
ils s'abonnent à une production et nous
on a ou la partagent équitablement en
quantité mais voilà j'appuie aussi sur
ce lien ce lien social un cas était le
rapprochement de la vie sociale pour
l'agriculteur la revalorisation du
métier les français qui attache beaucoup
d'importance aussi au respect de
l'environnement
quentin le guillon est ce que les
circuits courts respecte davantage que
les circuits longs c'est c'est sepric
aussi parlants bilan carbone bon il vend
à la ferme un autre
la voilà sur le 15 corps n'ont pas
encore optimisé un après il respecte
pour moi circuits courts ça veut pas
forcément rimer avec bio voilà circuits
coup on peut aujourd'hui hors du circuit
courant conventionnel et des produits
aussi de qualité ça il y en a mais ça
n'empêche pas que tout conventionnelle a
aussi conditionné ces 100 % bio voilà
après gage de qualité enfin
d'environnement chaque exploitation on
va dire fait au fait au mieux
comment dire sur sur l'embauché
voilà il ya de plus en plus embauche on
en parlait tout à l'heure après aussi
bon voilà ça avec les dangers aussi
surexploitation avec beaucoup
d'embauchés trouvait aussi du monde pour
pour embaucher parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est de plus en plus dur aussi de
trouver des gens qui sont prêts à venir
travailler dans des dans des
exploitations de retourner un petit peu
à la terre à quel coût on a une
concurrence il ya des exploitations et
en ile de france il ya des soucis de
main d'oeuvre quand même où on a une des
jambes à il faut un certain revenu
aujourd'hui travailler au smic les gens
ont de plus en plus de mal et qui sont
d'image aussi peut-être de l'agriculture
qui n'est plus celle d'avant oui alors
je trouve que l'image change
aujourd'hui on voit une agriculture
quand même qui a changé qui est plus du
tout la même
bah des gens on le voit avec aujourd'hui
la mécanisation les machines et autres
à l'époque il ya 50 ans ou même 70 ans
où il fallait la vache sous les chauds
quoi que ce soit pour aller dans les
champs labourés la pénibilité du travail
aujourd'hui celle là là quand même
largement disparu
il y en a encore bon maintenant c'est
oui peut-être l'image le les gens
reviennent certains reviennent à la
campagne devant nous en ile de france
ils ont surtout à la campagne parce que
l'immobilier beaucoup trop cher sur
paris et le grignotage urbain fait que
les jambes a du coup ces cartes de plus
en plus voilà alors circuits courts imec
l'environnement je pense que oui en
vendant sur du local c'est logique
voilà après bio pas peu importe pour moi
je pense que les deux sont capables de
travailler ensemble et de faire de la
qualité
oui encore cette question des émissions
de co2 puisque le
le circuit court n'empêche pas qu'il
faut des camions aussi pour transporter
des camionnettes sur les marchés ou
autre alain de l'angle peut mieux faire
en la matière en termes d'émissions de
co2 vrai qu'un gros camion d'allemands
une distribution émettra moins en terme
de quantité de produits transportés
qu'un petit finalement producteurs qui
va vendre ses produits sur le marché
en fait l'émission de co2 par rapport à
la distribution par rapport à la
logistique
c'est à la fois de la distance mais
c'est aussi de la massification
donc si on veut arriver à être vraiment
efficace sur des circuits peut-être à
l'échelle d'un département ou d'une
région
ça veut dire qu'il faut que cette région
soit repeupler dans le passé des gens
moi j'ai connu dans ma commune il y
avait il y avait trois épiceries le fait
qu'il y ait du monde ça pouvait aussi ça
permettait tout simplement de faire des
circuits plus courts mais mais c'est
vrai que la notion de carbone en termes
de distribution la notion de
massification elle est importante c'est
pas simplement la distance et mais tout
ça c'est c'est à partir de mouiller à la
volonté c'est en train de se travaille
et logistiques sont en train aussi se
perfectionner quel biais il ya des
plateformes qui regroupe davantage des
petits producteurs comment ça peut se
passer quand sonnera l'heure de
logistique possiblement en surgelé c'est
une logistique qui est adaptée dans une
logistique plus complexe c'est pas un
camion frigo qui vient tout seul c'est
c'est un camion c'est une box spéciale
qui va dans un système de logistique qui
qui n'existaient pas enfin qui quittent
plus
courante aux jurés on voit des choses
qui veut lui on ya de moins en moins de
courrier distribué mais il ya de plus en
plus aujourd'hui de colis qui sont en
train de se distribuer donc on voit bien
la logistique était en train de
s'adapter
elle est aussi en train de s'adapter
pour pour les circuits courts parce que
parce que internet on prête à l'heure
des décide des gens peuvent aujourd'hui
avec avec des chaînes youtube ça a
expliqué ce qu'ils font
donc ça rapproche forcément les gens
c'est c'est un rapprochement par
l'informatique
mais rien ne vaut à un moment quand même
le contact le fait de montchanin le
contact humain et donc ça peut pas être
à chaque fois c'est à dire que un
agriculteur qui fait de la vente directe
qui peut pas brassé non plus une demi
heure à discuter à chaque fois qu il
vend un colis ou enfin un panier de
légumes coiffé par contre il peut y
avoir des moments partagés c'est ça qui
est important c'est d'avoir des moments
où depuis la consommation y compris
peut-être des fois avec certains
intermédiaires jusqu'au jusqu'au
consommateur il faut que la production
jusqu'au consommateur il faut qu'il ya
un moment les gens se parlent mange
ensemble et du contact et de la
communication et de la promotion
évidemment qui passent par internet qui
passe aussi peut-être par des politiques
publiques
quentin review le fait de que des écoles
disent on va faire 40 % de nos menus
scolaires avec de la production locale
saas répond aussi de plus en plus oui ce
serait plus en plus bas donc en
politiques publiques qui soient oui bah
on le voit aussi ici en ile de france où
la volonté de l'île de france
aujourd'hui c'est d'ici ici quatre à
cinq ans de ramener des produits locaux
dans tout ce qui est cantine pour les
écoles pour les lycées pour même pour
l'épauler pour les maisons de retraite
les hôpitaux etc
donc c'est une volonté politique qui et
c'est très bien pour les producteurs
parce que certains peuvent partir en
circuit court mais en gros aujourd'hui
on peut voir que sur l'avenir des jeunes
peuvent s'installer et repartir aussi
dans des nouvelles diversification tech
maraîchage pour ses écoles ses lycées
etc etc je pense que c'est une très
bonne volonté c'est un très bon choix de
partir là dessus maintenant il faut ils
vont avoir quand même beaucoup de boulot
parce qu'il faut trouver tous toute la
nourriture capal voilà tous les
producteurs qu'ils pourraient capable de
et surtout à quel prix et alors dans ces
cas là est ce qu'on peut aussi adapter
sa production en tant qu'agriculteur par
rapport aux demandes des collectivités
notion monsieur on peut on peut adapter
sa production mais ça reste toujours ce
que je disais à quel prix voilà il peut
adapter en moi demain je je peux vendre
on peut vendre n'importe quoi à
n'importe qui ça sans problème à quel
prix voilà il en faut pour tous les
revenus aujourd'hui les gens n'ont pas
tous les moyens d'acheter du bio dans
des épiceries bio problème d'autres ont
besoin d'aller dans les gms donc il faut
pouvoir en faire à tout le monde à des
prix justes ça vous l'avez à l'esprit
quand vous fais tu m'as bien sûr bien
sûr il faut avoir le juste pour le
consommateur et pour l'agriculteur voilà
le producteur ne peut pas dire moi je
vais tout mettre pour moi et puis
terminer non il faut trouver le juste
milieu pour tout le monde
voilà il ya des personnes ont certaines
régions un peu plus aisés qui ont des
moyens d'acheter certains produits
d'autres pas dans certaines régions
reculées ou en campagne où les modes de
vie les revenus sont pas les mêmes voilà
il faut en prévoir pour tout le monde il
faut faire pour tout le monde denise
vuillon c'est valorisant aussi pour le
métier d'agriculteur de faire ces
circuits courts c'est important oui tout
à fait et je rebondis un petit peu sauf
que tu disais que où vous aussi vous
pensiez que c'était parce avait pas une
bonne image le métier de paysan c'est
vrai qu'à aller une dizaine d'années
c'était une insulte apaisant aujourd'hui
il ya énormément de jeunes qui
le en agriculture biologique 1 d'abord
ces créateurs d'emplois et couture
biologie comment créer de l'emploi il ya
besoin de main d'oeuvre et non matin et
puis quand vous êtes demandés par la
société civile on a besoin de vous oui
il ya eu vraiment un changement des
valeurs et des gens qui étudient dans
les villes et qui finalement se disent
on voit là il faut que la formation faut
que la formation
on va changer de vie finalement pour
avoir une qualité de vie aussi meilleur
j'imagine oui oui oui ça attire les
jeunes et c'est pour ça qu'on continue
doit sensibiliser aussi ce type
d'agriculture alain delon on va parler
de la concurrence internationale aussi
un qui pèse beaucoup sur sur
l'agriculture française est ce que le
des accords de libre-échange tips états
peuvent mettre en danger ses circuits
courts ou pas on a vu effectivement que
la tendance était à déréguler et à
vouloir cet échange parler des cantines
tout à l'heure la difficulté des
cantines ccc est dedans d un appel
d'offres qui font que normalement on
doit pas privilégier un produit local il
faut qu'il soit au moins l'échelle
européenne et donc il ya ya les
politiques sont timides par rapport à ça
c'est sûr et
ce soit par rapport aux histoires du
ceta samedi ça donne pas forcément une
bonne une bonne direction pour arriver à
aller vers la relocalisation parce que
en dehors des circuits courts l'idée
c'est bien de passer de la
mondialisation où on a imaginé que tout
pouvait produit que le monde était un
grand jardin et puis qu'on allait
produire les cornichons en inde parce
que le climat était favorable
en fait tout ça ça a amené la
monoculture et ça a amené la
problématique tous les soucis qu'on peut
avoir en termes d'environnement derrière
donc il faut penser la relocalisation et
esquibien sais c'est que le vraiment le
citoyen prenne conscience que dans son
acte d'achat lui il peut faire basculer
tout ça quoi et ça vous le sentez dans
les français qui ils ont pris conscience
de ça nous les produits bio sont
pratiquement vendu tout en plus cher que
les produits conventionnels et y'a rien
qui se développe autant que la bio en ce
moment donc ça veut bien dire que le
consommateur a pris conscience puis l'a
peut-être trouver des solutions il ya le
consentement à payer un petit peu plus
et où il règle et trouve les moyens
peut-être d'acheter des produits moins
transformés pour faire que son budget
consommation n'est pas forcément plus
élevé à passer le mou des gens en sont
la plupart des consommateurs qui vont
vers la bio vont aussi vers une
évolution de la mode de deux façons mon
petit bond faire leurs courses la façon
dont ils vont cuisiner tout ça quoi donc
c'est vraiment une prise de conscience
générale qui est une tendance
je crois que c'était aux derniers
chiffres les dernières de la bulle ont
montré qu'en fait la consommation elle
est importante chez les jeunes et la
grande distribution aussi le panier en
tout cas dans la grande distribution
d'un consommateur est légèrement en
baisse cette année les personnes vous
beaucoup sur internet aussi on sait pas
non plus que les les circuits courts
les gens préfèrent aussi d avoir des
commerces de proximité
quentin leguillon vous qui vous
diversifier en tout cas dans la
les élections de pâques notamment les
gens reviennent à des commerces de
proximité tout à fait qui est que ça
existe encore parce que certains villes
petites villes villages aujourd'hui
centre-ville ça n'existe plus je
voudrais déjà revenir un petit peu sur
tout ce qui est mondialisation on
parlait juste avant du ceta aujourd'hui
le ceta c'est pour nous un problème pour
la simple et bonne raison en fait c'est
le respect des normes
on demande en france des qualités à
voilà aux français aux agriculteurs
français conventionnelle et en bio c'est
à dire le bio en france c'est zéro
produit chimique de synthèse et le
conventionnel à des normes bien établi
aussi à respecter
aujourd'hui on veut faire rentrer en
france des produits qui ne respectent
pas ces normes là on le voit alors sur
le bio il ya encore du travail à faire
mais on voit des produits bio qui sont
importés en france
ils ont l'étiquette bio mais ne respecte
pas aujourd'hui la france en bio on est
peut être un des pays avec d'autres où
on est ultra carré c'est à dire 0 et
produits subissent le cahier des charges
est le plus fort mais on continue à
importer des produits qui ne respectent
pas pour moi le label bio arrivée en
france et c'est là le problème et c'est
là ce qu'on voudrait appuyé c'est que
les produits qui rentrent en france
respecte les normes françaises à des
produits moins chers peut-être peut-être
moins cher de meilleure qualité
non et je veux dire au jour de feu vert
dont pensent bon sanitaire sanitaire
sanitaires et sanitaire
voilà c'est tout ce problème là après on
a un petit paradoxe c'est qu'aujourd'hui
les français veulent revenir sur du
local
sauf que cette année l'année 2019 la
france a été importateur bien plus
qu'elle n'a exporté et c'est là le
problème en fait c'est que quand on voit
que la france a importé plus de produits
qu'elle n'a exporté c'est que le pays va
mal
c'était pas le cas auparavant bien sûr
non avant on arrivait à être toujours un
petit peu plus fort en terme d'exposants
voilà aujourd'hui en france on est
capable de produire et de manger à notre
faim en france et d'exporter
sauf qu'aujourd'hui on en exporte 1 une
partie mais on en importe et on importe
des produits qui sont souvent bas comme
disait tout à l'heure du maïs du soja de
certains pays où logeait motorisés un
exemple tout bête mois sur
l'exploitation pour ramener une péniche
à un port français comme dunkerque
aujourd'hui il est moins cher de faire
venir une péniche du canada que de
prendre tous les camions en quantité
pour remplir la péniche qui viennent de
france dès fois d'une centaine de
kilomètres et les hawks est là le
problème aujourd'hui si on nous dit les
mieux de faire venir une péniche parce
que ça nous coûte moins cher là ça va
pas bien et la qualité souvent ne répond
pas on va passer aux à vos questions et
avoue remarques et questions des
internautes
[Musique]
question pour vous alain de l'angle
extrêmement chers comparés aux magasins
discount alors oui peut être meilleur
pour les petits salaires et des revenus
sociaux impossible sinon le 15 ce sont
les doigts qui ne mange alors
effectivement il ya ce problème de
tarifs 1 et 2 des français qui n'ont pas
beaucoup d'argent pour pouvoir se
tourner vers vers des produits
en vente directe et de meilleure qualité
est ce qu'un jour ce problème pourrait
être résolu selon vous c'est un problème
éternel c'est la répartition des
richesses et c'est pas pendant des
années on a cru que vous que tout le
monde puisse manger à sa faim il fallait
baisser le prix de l'alimentation on
pouvait aussi imaginer que vous pouvez
relever les salaires et faire que chacun
ait les moyens de bien se nourrir
donc on est vraiment dans une
problématique de politique globale les
deux sociétés qui il faut faire que les
richesses doivent être mieux réparti et
l'alimentation doit être passé des
choses prioritaires a des qualités
une question pour vous donner huyon les
amap par exemple ne sont pas du tout
adaptés à la vie trépidante des
travailleurs question d'horaire
comment faire question d'horaire on a
choisi au lieu à 20h ou autres ou à 19h
comment on fait pour pouvoir baisser
c'est mieux que le matin comme sur le
marché parce que plus personne ne peut
aller au marché
donc on a pensé que c'était voilà après
la sortie de l'école après la sortie du
travail à paris par exemple les amap me
distribuer encore plus tard que chez
nous chez nous c'est 17 19 heures mais
bon on trouve toujours dans une famille
quelqu'un qui peut venir chercher son
panier on peut pas faire mieux on peut
difficilement voilà satisfaire tous les
horaires un système qui peut être
amélioré les industriels qui sentent la
tendance et nous vendent du prétendu
produits hexagonal ajoutez à cela les
normes européennes la lâcheté des élus
quant à la traçabilité des denrées qui
ne facilite pas une consommation
réfléchie et contrôler c'était la
question de départ un petit peu quentin
le guillou est-ce que ça la qualité est
vraiment garantir à 100% avec ses
circuits courts ou pas quand on mange
des produits français on a une norme
française
on sait sur quoi on se base voilà mois
ci dans une grande surface par exemple
on peut dire ce produit là et a été
et locales est ce que ça ne garantit sa
provenance sa nous garantit une qualité
française voilà il est locale tant qu'il
ait marqué france est stipulé france et
qu'il est bien fait en france et
produits transformés peu importe en
france on a des normes françaises après
quand les gens s'orientent
malheureusement aujourd'hui on a un
train de vie pour certaines personnes où
ils ont peut-être qu'un quart d'heure ou
20 minutes le midi pour manger
malheureusement ces gens là s'oriente
sur des plats préparés là le gage de la
qualité il est à leur bon vouloir voilà
aujourd'hui sur des plats préparés et ça
peut dû préparer local chez eux la
veille au soir c'est très bien mais en
achetant ou en allant c'est le problème
un petit peu qu'on a en france
aujourd'hui on va critiquer certains
modes l'accueil futur plus cher
aujourd'hui indéniablement pas forcément
pas forcément faux la qualité on peut la
voir quand respecte plusieurs choses la
saison le local le français là la
qualité on l'a mais après quand on
entend les gens qui qui sont jamais
assez content de la qualité ou quoi que
ce soit et puis qu'on arrive le vendredi
soir ou le samedi qui est une forme
parfaite voilà et puis qui font la queue
sur les fast food ou dans des chaînes
alimentaires et autres ou qui mange le
midi des plats surgelés préparer fait
avec je ne sais quelle viande ou quoi
que ce soit ça on a un petit peu du mal
à l'entendre voilà on veut nous faire la
leçon
on essaye de bien faire mais qu'on nous
respecte aussi donc éventuellement
conviennent à ce que les gens ils
viennent chercher chez nous manger
français local de saison de qualité
merci beaucoup en tout cas à tous les
trois d'avoir répondu à nos questions
sur rt france sujet ô combien
passionnant merci beaucoup c'est la fin
de deux politiques mag
restez avec nous l'info à suivre
[Musique]
qui sont venus dans notre village deux
fois
[Musique]